عام 2017 الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
يختار المغرب كاول بلد المغاربيه يزوره
بعد انتخابه رئيسا لفرنسا زياره وطدت
العلاقه بين الحنيفين التقليديين لكن هذه
العلاقات سادها الفتور في الاونه الاخيره
لاسباب عده ابرزها قرار فرنسا في اين
سبتمبر 2021 تقليص عدد تاشيرات الممنوحه
للمغرب والجزائر الى النصف مبرره
مهاجرين غير نظامين تريد باريس
عطاء حقوقيون ومثقفون ووسائل اعلام
المحليه
الصحراء الغربيه ملف التوتر ايضا بين
البلدين الرباط تحث باريس على الاعتراف
بسيادتها على هذه المنطقه المتنازع عليها
مع جبهه البوليساريو مثل ما فعلت الولايات
المتحده اواخر العام 2020 في اطار اتفاق
شمل ايضا تطبيع المغرب على قاته مع
اسرائيل
الفتور في العلاقات بين البلدين يعود ايضا
الى اتهام المغرب في تحقيق نشرته وسائل
اعلام دوليه سيف العام الماضي باستعمال
تطبيق
هواتف سياسيين فرنسيين بينهم الرئيس مكروه
الاتهام الذين فتحوا الرباط
قضائيه ضد الصحف التي نشرته في فرنسا
الرئيس الفرنسيه
الاولى من العام المقبل بعد ان ادى التوتر
العلاقات بين البلدين الى الغاء زياره له
كانت مقرران نهايه الشهر اكتوبر الماضي